bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 l'actu
de ce lundi 14 avril nous allons
démarrer avec la Fédération des Motards
en Colère une fédération qui a organisé
ce samedi près de 80 points de
rassemblement dans toute la France pour
dire non au projet de réduction de la
vitesse sur les départementales la
vitesse qui pourrait passer de 80 à 80 à
de 90 à 80 km/h dans les Yvelines les
motards vous le voyez sur ces images ce
sont rassemblés à Louveciennes pour
prendre la direction ensuite de la
manifestation parisienne devant le
château de Vincennes ils disent en avoir
assez de la politique punitive axée sur
la politique du chiffre pour eux une
autre sécurité routière est possible et
je vous propose d'écouter une des
adhérentes de la Fédération elle
s'appelle Patricia elle explique son
point de vue au micro d'Olivier
Maniscalco et de Patrick
on fera mieux de faire du préventif que
du répressif et que c'est de l'argent
facile tout simplement pas j'aurais pu
se faire du préventif peut-être avec
certaines campagnes de sensibilisation
ou faire comme dans d'autres pays où il
y a des endroits où on peut rouler et
que les gens puissent se défouler aussi
plutôt que de mettre des radars tout le
temps où on a toujours les yeux
éventuellement sur le compteur et là je
trouve que c'est plus dangereux que
quand on peut rouler correctement quoi
à l'éducation maintenant une première
mouture de la carte scolaire 2014 a été
dévoilée à la rentrée prochaine le
département devrait être accueillir 153
élèves supplémentaires dans les écoles
maternelles et primaires cela se traduit
directement par l'ouverture de 79
classes dans le département et sur notre
secteur vous allez le découvrir à
Élancourt à les hameau à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux ou encore à
Voisins le bretonneux voilà pour ces
premières classes ouvertes dans ces
villes à Guyancourt des ouvertures de
classe sont également prévues cette fois
dans quatre et puis enfin attrape dans
trois écoles primaires et puis autour de
50 ans en Yvelines des ouvertures de
classe sont également envisagées à
Maurepas à plaisir et à
Saint-Cyr-l'École et puis parallèlement
assez ouvertures il y a des fermetures
qui sont programmées elles sont au
nombre de 65 dans le département et sur
l'agglomération 5 continents et le
concerne directement 3 villes lui en
cours manileamo et trap et puis à noter
que d'autres mesures pourraient aussi
être prises à la rentrée de septembre
l'ouverture d'une cuisse une classe pour
l'Inclusion Scolaire à Guyancourt au
sein de l'école primaire Robespierre et
puis un renforcement de personnel pour
le collège cette fois Gagarine c'est la
trappe dans le cadre du réseau
d'éducation prioritaire alors il reste
une autre interrogation la réforme du
temps scolaire Benoît Hamon le nouveau
ministre de l'éducation nationale devra
trancher la question assouplissement ou
pas en attendant les communes ont
jusqu'à la fin du mois d'avril pour
présenter leur projet d'école
politique maintenant sans surprise
pierre Badi a été réélu président du
Conseil général des Yvelines un fauteuil
qu'il retrouve après l'avoir perdu en
2009 à la suite d'affaires judiciaires à
l'inschmitz qui donc la présidence pour
redevenir simple conseiller général un
arrangement entre amis condamne les élus
de l'opposition
a été élu ce vendredi à bulletin secret
sans surprise président du Conseil
général des Yvelines l'élection
intervient une semaine après l'annonce
de la démission d'Alain Schmitz l'ancien
président UMP du conseil général Alain
Schmitz avait pourtant assuré quelques
mois auparavant qu'il souhaitait aller
au bout de son mandat en mars 2015 dans
la vie lorsqu'on fait partie d'une
équipe il faut savoir interchanger les
places à des moments donnés il y en a
qui jouent c'est un peu comme au PSG il
y en a qui jouent un peu plus de vent
d'autres qui jouent un peu plus derrière
et puis voilà pierre Bédi avait déjà été
président du conseil général entre 2005
et 2009 il avait dû quitter son siège
après avoir été condamné pour délit
d'initier et prise illégales d'intérêt 5
ans plus tard il est réélu avec 26 voix
pour 9 voix pour le candidat de la
gauche André Silvestre et de vote blanc
et nuls deux conseillères générales
étaient absentes et n'avait pas donné de
pouvoir Christine Boutin et Fanny
hervera à l'issue du vote Pierre-Bénite
a fait un discours très politique où il
a défendu l'utilité des conseils
généraux il a évoqué un effort de
maîtrise de la dépense publique et une
ambition pour mener à bien des missions
de solidarité et des actions en faveur
de l'emploi plus qu'un discours
d'installation une vraie feuille de
route soumise aux élus et ce qui m'a
frappé c'est le moment ambition pour le
département à un moment même ou dans son
discours de politique générale le
Premier ministre a à évoqué la
disparition des départements et je pense
que c'est au contraire quand c'est le
devenir département est aléatoire qu'il
faut être encore plus ambitieux au
service des yvelinois donc j'ai reçu le
message 5 sur 5 de Pierre bélier du côté
de l'opposition cette passation de
pouvoir entre un Schmitt et Pierre Bédié
et qualifié de révolution de palais
quelque chose qui ressemble l'avantage
ce que je faisais une révolution de
palais qui a une véritable exercice
démocratique
je maintiens je pense qu'il y a eu des
pressions des manœuvres politiciennes
pour enlever là où on est arrivé
aujourd'hui après une interruption de
quelques minutes la séance a repris
classiquement 33 points était inscrits à
l'ordre du jour
allez un tout autre sujet pour continuer
ce vous le savez ce sont les vacances de
Pâques qui ont démarré et ce sont
également les Stylus qui sont de sortie
à Manille les hameaux et pour en parler
avec nous ce soir Frédéric du lac
bonsoir vous êtes mère adjointe en
charge notamment des centres sociaux et
puis vous avez accompagné de Gaspard
herblue vous animez des ateliers pendant
cette semaine exactement vous parlez
vous pouvez nous faire une petite démo
des ateliers
vous êtes boxeur et vous allez animer
pendant toute cette semaine des ateliers
les Stylus ça a donc démarré depuis
samedi et avant d'en discuter avec vous
de ce qui va se passer pendant toute
cette semaine on va regarder d'abord ce
reportage c'était samedi avec Olivier
Maniscalco et Patrick
la ruban en fait à Magny-les-Hameaux
pour sa treizième édition le festival
Stylus ouvrait ce week-end dans le
quartier du Buisson au programme des
ateliers proposant une palette variée
initiation au sport urbain concours de
graphe ou encore le traditionnel battle
de hip-hop ou le public joue le rôle de
membres du jury on était partagé par une
part de vote qui vient du jury et enfin
pour les deux et demande du jury et puis
le troisième en fait c'est avec la
participation du public qui vote avec un
système de panneau rouge ou panneau bleu
moi c'est pas mal ouais ça crée aussi
une interaction entre nous danseurs et
puis public aussi ça ça les emmène à
s'intéresser un peu plus à ce qu'on fait
aussi quoi ils se retrouvent plus à cœur
que ce que j'adore objectif de la
journée valoriser la pluralité urbaine
le vainqueur du concours de graphe se
voyait même remettre un chèque de 200
euros on s'est un petit prix symbolique
en réalité mais bon ça nous permet de ça
nous permet de faire découvrir aux gens
une culture un peu plus un peu plus
urbaine on en voit quelque fois fleurir
à droite et à gauche mais là vraiment on
a des on a des spécimens qui sont assez
formidables donc ça nous réjouit et
pendant que les bboys et graffeurs
régalaient le public dehors les plus
petits nous offrait également un beau
spectacle
je faisais la trottinette en fait laver
quelqu'un qui est tombé moi aussi je
suis tombé le festival va se poursuivre
jusqu'au 18 avril un festival qui se
conclura par une journée d'activité
gratuite au skatepark vendredi prochain
et lors de ces stylos Manille d'amour on
ne fait pas que de la crotteinette de
trottinette les stylos a été créé il y a
13 ans en 2001 pourquoi avoir créé ce
festival des styles urbain à
magny-les-maux si vous voulez ça
correspond à une demande des jeunes qui
faisait partie du service jeunesse à
l'époque était en tout début de création
et
les jeunes qui venaient là nous
proposaient toujours des choses bon on
pouvait pas leur offrir ou toujours les
mêmes choses et puis on a fait un
sondage au collège
au niveau des collégiens on leur a
demandé dans toutes les classes
jusqu'à la troisième on leur a dit mais
qu'est-ce qui vous manque à Manille
qu'est-ce qui manque pour les jeunes à
Manille etc et le en grande majorité
nous ont tous répondu à un skatepark
donc on s'est dit en discutant avec en
discutant avec eux après au service
jeunesse on leur a dit qu'est-ce que
vous voulez faire dans un skatepark dans
un skatepark il y a du roller il y a du
BMX il y a du VTT il y a
de la trottinette si on veut enfin bon
voilà et donc
du coup avant de préfigurer le skatepark
on a d'abord mis en place certains des
escapes il a vu le jour en 2008 et voilà
et les Stylus sont restés voilà et la
journée du vendredi va se passer au
skatepark alors elle a démarré donc
c'est ce festival a démarré samedi on a
vu le reportage pendant toute la semaine
il va y avoir des ateliers Gaspard vous
serez l'un des animateurs de ces
ateliers et les animateurs jeunesse et
puis il y a des animateurs extérieurs
qu'est-ce que vous allez proposer on a
commencé ce matin en fait j'ai plusieurs
groupes j'ai un groupe d'enfants qui ont
plutôt 7-8 ans que j'ai eu une heure
chacun le matin avec eux on fait
vraiment du beatbox et de la perfection
corporelle l'après-midi je propose
d'abord un atelier de porter acrobatique
et ensuite un joli de human beatbox
technique qui prend du temps mais bon
comme toute magie il y a quand même des
trucs derrière donc c'est vraiment une
technique de qu'on voilà on utilise la
bouche pour faire des grosses caisses
avec les lèvres par exemple
ça c'est vraiment un son de base après
chacun développe un peu sa technique
mais c'est vraiment un exercice qu'on a
obtenu des résultats
ils arrivent en une semaine à pouvoir
produire des sons en fait avec les
enfants de 7-8 ans ça va assez vite
parce qu'ils sont pas encore trop
retenus par leur pudeur donc ils
osent vraiment se lancer essayer à
l'adolescence parfois selon les âges
c'est un peu plus difficile mais il y a
des adolescents qui ont déjà un petit
bagage qui sont déjà issus un peu de
cette culture là et donc parfois il
suffit juste de d'aller tirer des fils
qui sont déjà là quoi et quand vous
parlez de culture justement comment on
peut la définir cette culture bah c'est
sûr que ce cette technique là elle vient
quand même de la culture hip-hop
maintenant il y a le beatboxing à
utiliser dans plein de styles musicaux
différents et n'est pas cantonné à la
culture hip-hop
voilà il y a un message intéressant dans
cette culture que déjà on n'a pas besoin
de grand chose pour pouvoir pratiquer ça
et se développer et ensuite ben voilà
c'est vraiment la persévérance et le
partage aussi c'est une technique que
moi j'ai développé en échangeant avec
d'autres donc voilà c'est un message de
partage et de et de volonté aussi et
puis de plaisir surtout d'amusement donc
beatbox vous avez dit porter acrobaté
il met plusieurs disciplines parce que
je suis aussi artiste de cirque je fais
de la jonglerie des portes acrobatiques
et donc les portables chromatiques sont
liés à un atelier breakdance donc avec
celui qui intervenu avec moi Julien ils
apprennent de la breakdance et moi je
leur apprends aussi des porter
acrobatiques donc c'est vraiment
issu du cirque donc voilà porter
quelqu'un debout sur ses épaules faire
des pyramides et on prépare un petit
spectacle dans lequel il y aura des
portraits chromatiques et de la
breakdance parce que la finalité c'est
c'est vendredi prochain voilà un dis pas
que c'est un bien vraiment mais ça
serait une restitution en fait
le spectacle restitution
dans l'après-midi
alors il paraît la météo n'annonce pas
un super temps donc il y a on a
peut-être déjà avec la météo c'est un
peu difficile de s'y retrouver une
solution de recours si jamais ça
fonctionne pas ou ce qu'elle parte à
cause du mauvais temps peut-être ça
serait dans le gymnase et alors en plus
de la restitution propose aussi des
ateliers d'initiation au tout-venant
donc si vous voulez venir vendredi
prochain
donc vendredi restitution des ateliers
qui ont lieu toute la semaine il y a pas
que beatbox il y a aussi d'autres
d'autres activités et puis effectivement
si tout le monde veut devenir essayer au
beatbox on peut on peut venir essayer
vendredi donc au skatepark de Manille ou
au gymnase de l'Aune si jamais il fait
pas beau merci en tout cas à vous deux
d'être venu à une petite démoli encore
un petit son pour finir
comme vous voulez
merci d'accord merci beaucoup à vous
d'être venu en plateau allez sur cette
huit à l'actuée est terminée merci de
votre attention attention pardon la
formation revient demain mardi toujours
en direct à 18h dans quelques instants
vous avez rendez-vous avec le 7 8 sport
avec Anthony Rech bonne soirée